i love this cat i'll go give her her hug
[Music]
it's finally christmas season when i was
younger i would always run and grab the
toys catalogs and i would just go
through every page and circle every
single toy that i wanted for christmas
that year so today what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna go and review the top selling
toys from target i have two of my
friends coming by to help me out because
i really needed some expert advice on
this one i'm a toy expert
i'm dj i'm a toy expert and no one knows
more about toys than i do
what's your favorite toy right now what
i like my spy gear your spy gear uh
we're gonna check out what's in those
credits you can tell me what you like
about it if you think it's silly if you
think it's cool what about if it's a toy
i don't like you say that too you want
us to open up that one i do want to open
it all right let's see what's inside
[Music]
that's how you open toys on christmas
day
you're like
go ahead this is your show
[Music]
tell me tell me what that face needs i
know some kids love this toy but i don't
know why i'll give her up and give it to
them for their birthday if they want if
your dad got you elmo for christmas and
this was under the tree how happy would
you be
elmo
you really like elmo yes i play alma
wake up coconut but i also want and eat
my candy i don't care to like wait to
get my stuffed animals all my stuffed
animals right away so i gotta like like
rub the eggs and all that stuff in order
to get my stuffed animals what is this
what is this
yeah we're good on this i'm gonna put
this on the side and we're gonna see
what else is over there okay
a cat
[Music]
cut it out i'll cut it for you right
this is where that editor puts that
graphic five years later
whoa
we finally did it i got you some milk
mia you talk
my name i love this cat i'll go give her
her hug
he he likes to eat milk
it's so good go ahead rip it apart like
a christmas morning man
[Applause]
we're loaded
oh and now we look like now he looks oh
did it did he get you
but it can't even tell how do you know
who wins does it keep score
that beef
let's turn off this thing yes is this a
toy that you would recommend life for
your friend i like the toy but i hate
the noise and if you want to hide i mean
you can at least turn the toy off for a
second
how would you score
elmo you give them a five if you really
really love them or you give them a one
if you only like them a little bit
uh five five the ones that i really
liked better was the laser x and what
about the kitten a five five out of five
this shouldn't be the top selling turn
the target you don't do anything with it
you love both of those toys yes you can
only get the elmo or the cat which one
would you get
are you hoping for any of these gifts
under your tree this christmas that one
i like the grappler and my kitten is my
favorite toy you can bring a laser ex
home and play whenever you want whatever
time
the best man merry christmas happy
holidays peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you